Now that we have a loaded image, we need to draw that image to the canvas via
the canvas.drawImage API. This function takes the image object itself as well
as the locations on the canvas that we'd like to draw that image. As you can
see, there are some other parameters that drawImage takes. Don't worry about
those just yet. For now you can leave those blank. By the way, if you are ever
interested in finding out more about an API for HTML5 development, make sure
you check out webplatform.org. It's a nifty little space where all your
questions can be answered. For our next step, why don't you go ahead and fill in
the onLoad function that we defined earlier. So that rather than logging a
message to the console, instead, it draws the image at pixel location 192 by 192.